está extendiéndose rápidamente por el
mundo la variante delta conocida
científicamente como be 1.6 17.2 fue
identificada inicialmente en india en
octubre de 2020 ahora está presente en
al menos 104 países y ya es dominante en
india reino unido y eeuu científicos
afirman que se propaga un 225 por ciento
más rápidamente que la versión original
de kobe 19 un nuevo estudio descubrió
que la gente contagiada por la variante
delta tenía más de 1000 copias del virus
en su sistema respiratorio comparado a
los que se contagiaron con el virus
original y una persona que contrae la
variante delta también se convierte en
vector de contagio más rápido en europa
oficiales advierten el arribo de una
cuarta ola la variante delta que
inicialmente llegó de la india apareció
algunas semanas atrás en nuestro país
como saben es más contagiosa está
progresivamente reemplazando todas las
otras variantes del coronavirus que
existen y pronto será la más presente
probablemente ya este fin de semana
científicos han estudiado la efectividad
de las vacunas aprobadas en el reino
unido
de la población ha sido totalmente
vacunado alrededor de dos tercios
recibieron astrazéneca después de dos
dosis la vacuna ha demostrado ser 60 por
ciento efectiva contra delta pero 92 por
ciento efectiva en prevenir la
enfermedad severa
resultados similares demostraron que la
vacuna faizabad intec el 64 por ciento
efectiva contra la variante pero 96 por
ciento efectiva en evitar casos críticos
también sabemos que las vacunas
autorizadas previenen la enfermedad
grave hospitalización y muerte por la
variante delta y estos resultados han
sido observados no solo aquí pero en
otros países también facer dice que está
trabajando en una vacuna de refuerzo
para incrementar inmunidad contra la
variante delta la carrera ahora es
vacunar a la población antes de que el
virus pueda mutar nuevamente